this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer simple
malfunctions have plagued spaceflight
from its inception it goes without
saying that pushing things into space
with controlled explosions is a
treacherous affair and many rocket
launches have failed over simple
problems the three crew members of Soyuz
11 became the first and only humans to
die in space after the explosive bolts
holding the service module and descent
module together fired a routine
procedure but the bolts were designed to
fire sequentially one after the other on
this occasion they fired simultaneously
and the combined explosive force
loosened a seal separating the crew from
the vacuum of space within a minute the
crew were dead
more recently SpaceX its first launch
failed simply because they left their
rocket exposed to sea air for too long
allowing it to rust an aluminium nut
securing the fuel pump Inlet pressure
transducer when it failed fuel began to
leak down the outside of the engine and
thrust chamber and caught fire the fire
caused a loss of pneumatic pressure
forcing valves to close and thus cutting
thrust
SpaceX's first rocket fell out of the
sky over a simple oversight of aluminium
weakness to corrosion
after this flight SpaceX switched to
rust resistant stainless steel fasteners
which are actually cheaper to begin with
but about two and a half times heavier
there is very little margin for error in
space flight tiny oversights like this
lead to catastrophic failure and this is
exactly what happened to what was
intended to be the first successful
planetary flyby in human history the
Mariner won on July 22nd 1962 Mariner 1
launched from Cape Canaveral on a
mission intended to fly by Venus and
collect data on its temperature and
atmosphere for just 293 seconds into its
flight the Range Safety Officer gave the
command to self-destruct the rocket over
an unpopulated area of the Atlantic
seeing that its trajectory was taking it
to a crash landing possibly in busy
shipping lanes or land despite the
booster performing nominally the rocket
took an own program diol left turned and
steering commands were unresponsive with
just six seconds remaining before the
mariner 1 probe was scheduled to
separate and ground control would be
lost that officer made the decision to
send the
self-destruct command to understand what
went wrong we first need to learn a
little about how the Atlas Agena rocket
which the Mariner one probe was perched
upon worked the Atlas booster rocket
used two radar systems to maintain its
trajectory along its intended route a
rate system which measured its velocity
using Doppler shift measurements from a
ground-based beacon and a track system
which measured its distance and angle
relative to an antenna located near its
launch site shortly into the launch the
first problem occurred the rate system
failed the track system should have been
capable of handling navigation by itself
the two systems working together formed
some redundancy in measurements to allow
for a small margin of error this is why
previous launches using the Atlas Aegina
rockets went off without a hitch but on
this occasion the rate system failed the
code designed to interpret the distance
and angle measurements had a simple
error this is the notation the position
measurement should have had and this was
the notation it actually had in the code
it was missing an overmare this dot
stands for the first derivative of the
position which gives us the velocity and
the overbear simply means to take the
average of the values giving a smooth
add value for the velocity which helps
remove any fluctuations of measurement
because this bear was missing the rocket
guidance computer was being fed erotic
information about the Rockets velocity
and it began trying to compensate for
them leading to actual erotic flight
this was the point the Range Safety
Officer recognized something was wrong
and initiated the self-destruct command
an incredibly simple mistake that should
have been caught but these were the
early days of programming we didn't have
fancy computer interfaces for writing
code with compiling software and error
detection the code for the guidance
computer was mostly written in Fortran
an early coding language Fortran which
stood for a formula translation was used
to translate mathematical equations into
code and was handwritten or typed on a
typewriter but a computer cannot
understand code by itself it needs to be
translated into binary machine code to
work this is where punch cards came into
play punch cards are thick rectangular
pieces of paper with long rows of
repeating numbers 0 through 9 running
down there Lent in 80 columns each caret
held one line of code would each column
representing one character of code in
line to represent a number you simply
punched out the corresponding number in
the sheath to represent letters and
symbols required you to punch out
additional holes this sheet has all the
possible hole punch combinations
required for Fortran coding to give you
an example this was done on a card punch
machine where you had to manually type
out each line of the code again once you
had converted all your code to punch
carrots the carrots would be sent
through a compiler where they would be
converted to binary if a hole was
present a circuit would be completed
through a particular set of contacts and
thus a binary signal was produced the
compiler then produced a new set of
carrots that the computer could actually
understand obviously this method of
coding is much more tedious and
difficult to fact-check when compared to
present-day user interfaces it's no
excuse but obviously mistakes were much
easier to make and this particular
mistake ended up causing NASA eighteen
point five million dollars in 1962 which
is about a hundred and fifty million
dollars today the code was corrected and
just a month later Mariner 2 was
launched on it's three and a half month
flight to Venus on its way Mariner 2
detected solar winds for the first time
the constant stream of charged particles
emitted from the Sun it measured
interplanetary dust levels and during
its flyby of Venus revealed information
about the planets temperature and
atmosphere Mariner 2 is now floating
somewhere in orbit around the Sun
learning from our mistakes is a common
theme in human history which is why I
find brilliant style of teaching
complicated subjects fantastic take this
course on classical mechanics it takes
you through the fundamentals of the
physics of motion an essential skill for
any rocket engineer it will give you
short digestible overviews of the
problem and then give you a problem of
your own to solve if you get it correct
you advance forward if you get it wrong
however it will tell you exactly why and
teach you more about the subject
allowing you to learn from your own
mistakes and hopefully not repeat them
this is encapsulated in their principles
of learning by allowing for failure and
acknowledging it happens one is open to
correcting misconceptions and errors
which furthers understanding of the
topic to support real engineering and
learn more about brilliant go to
brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and sign up for free the
first 73 people to sign up with this
link will get 20% off their annual
premium subscription as
always thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for watching
I recently featured on the life noggin
channel as an animated version of myself
to teach you about what makes the
perfect City the link to that is on the
screen now if you would like to join the
real engineering community I have
recently set up a subreddit and discord
server where we discuss everything
engineering related and more the link
for those are in the description